[Music]
cynthia is with us cynthia is in des
moines iowa hi cynthia how are you
hi dave doing great thanks for taking my
call sure um i have a quick question so
i am on
i am hoping to get on to baby step four
really soon
so my question is around baby step four
um i'm wanting to contribute about 15 to
my 401k right hoping like this next
paycheck or possibly in february
um but i'm noticing that the market is
well it's in the toilet so
should i really contribute at this time
or should i skip it and move on to like
something else or when i was a little
kid
my mama would take us to a store called
kmart
and kmart would in the middle of the day
run these little sails they called them
blue light special blue light special
they would turn on a blue light over the
top of the
whatever area and uh you could go over
there and get you a coffee pot on sale
or whatever that's what you're that's
what we're having right now darling this
is called a blue light special you need
to buy water it's on sale buy while it's
on sale
okay so buy it okay so you know why
how old are you
i'm 40-ish okay 48
own it own it i'm 61. i'm already proud
of it so there you go but the uh uh
yeah so here's the thing uh uh
in 20 years
where do you think an average
of companies that sound like this
apple coca-cola
mcdonald's
boeing
microsoft
home depot
an on average as a group now there'll be
some one or two that fail
but on average as a group an aggregate
of that group 20 years from now are they
going to be worth more or less
well ideally more
well not only ideally there would be the
that's what has always happened in
history 100 percent of the time so far
in the american stock market's history
now obviously the world can fall apart
and we can just blow this whole thing up
called america but if anything stays
similar to what it is
20 years from today it's going to be up
and you will be glad that you bought in
the cold winter of
2022 when the market was freezing to
death and down
because
of whatever was going on out there i
haven't even seen always something going
on how far down is it i don't even look
i dropped 500 points in one day the
other day but it's just it's back and
forth it's out of 30 000. 500 points
used to be a lot it's not anymore but
yeah yeah it's uh ukraine and uh and
biden mumbling and
they can't nobody you know nobody's
getting uh idea that he's going to do
anything and so the market's just
unstable geopolitical crap always
destabilizes the market it always has
i mean this little thing happens on the
other side of the world and pump all of
a sudden
because people just have this little
black cloud following around on wall
street just waiting for the next thing
waiting on the next bad thing and then
they're psychological as it can be
but uh um bitcoins in half oh god who
knew
that was gonna happen
and so anybody with investing wisdom of
more than eight to ten years yeah yeah
that's true but um yeah it's fairly
fairly easy predictor but fairly you
know easy predictor and this is just a
you know
it is a geopolitical driven it's not
economic driven and it's not profits the
profits of the companies involved have
not changed so are they suddenly worth
less right
no they're so worth what they were worth
it's just they're scared they might be
down in the future because of war with
russia or china or destabilization of
the political environment all that kind
of crap
so do i think all that's going to happen
nope
i think there's going to be problems and
there's going to be times when there's
not problems and the market's going to
go up the market's going to go down and
i only people get hurt on a roller
coaster are those that jump off in the
middle of the route